welcome to the second part of my
three-part series analyzing the Dark
Souls 2 gameplay revealed for the 11th
of April this video will try to
extrapolate what we can expect from the
game in terms of gameplay I'm aiming to
limit gameplay footage for this video
and the next due to copyright fears
although this is a gameplay analysis so
I don't think I'm gonna have much
success when I get to actually editing
the video regardless I'll try keep it
short clear and concise the first thing
to notice is the main character and the
fairly standard Souls UI graphical
quality and animation of the player and
the environment has dramatically
improved and this becomes evident when
he starts walking notice the swaying
grass and improved cloth physics just
now you'll have noticed that the weapon
slots
actually fold away when not in use to
provide more of us cinematic feel when
the light shine through from this angle
it illuminates more particles in the air
as the gameplay continues you begin to
notice that the lighting is one of the
most impressive things about this new
engine especially evident when you do
things like lighting the bonfire the
reflection and realism of this light is
almost perfect it's worth noting that
many players find the animations
slightly off for awkward but I think
they're a huge improvement each to their
own I guess so on to combat targeting is
the same if you look carefully you'll
notice that there's actually been a
change to the move sets assuming the
player is just pressing r1 it seems like
there are at least three unique combos
to perform with r1 spam as opposed to
two in previous games this becomes more
evident when the player dual wield
swords the first attack is a right
handed the second left-handed and third
uses both weapons to swipe down as
expected from the first cinematic
trailer dual wielding is clearly going
to play more of a significant role in
the game which is really exciting
expect more unique attacks and weapon
combinations as you'd expect from a
Souls game there's heavy emphasis on
progressing with your shield up at all
times
the developers stated that the first
part of the game will consist of
stressful tense gameplay where there are
less enemies but each encounter is
significant the latter part of the
gameplay will be heavily action-oriented
with more constant encounters this is a
good way to introduce new players to the
game while retaining the same tense
gameplay that the souls games are
for I expect traps to be a huge part of
the suspense in the first part of the
game and you can probably say that
coming through here here again we see
three unique attack animations for
simple our one spam one thing you'll
notice as we progress is the change in
atmosphere compared to Dark Souls there
are more similarities to Demon Souls
here and one of the reasons for this is
probably the darker environments
assumedly you can choose to progress
through these environments like you
would in the tomb of the giants
alternatively you can sacrifice your
left hand slot for a torch which
illuminates your environment so you can
see what's going to kill you
so many people have pointed out that the
torch blocks 100% physical damage here
which I assume will be changed since the
UI wrongly shows that you actually have
a a shield equipped at this point you
will have noticed that the character's
taking a fare beating firstly this is a
demo and it's common for Souls demos at
least to feature a over geared and over
leveled character this looks like an
early part of the game and the character
already has a huge supply of health
insurance and also equipment don't worry
too much about the nuances of gameplay
since it will actually take an entire
playthrough not just a demo to
accurately judge it in terms of rolling
it's worth noting that the player rolls
twice perpendicular to the original
position here instead of at the second
roll rotating around the enemies like it
would normally be expected in Dark Souls
developers have said that they've put
heavy emphasis on the context
appropriate reactions of enemies you're
behind this enemy and he reacts
appropriately they say this is part of
forging an experience that forces you to
strategize and think logically expect
every enemy or at least most of them to
have vastly improved AI and reactions
here the player also panics spamming his
d-pad he unequipped the torch and also
scrolls through his spell slot which
reveals a few things to us it has the
text l 2 semi-colon 10 assumedly this
means that the spell is at level 2 with
10 charges so this would be a new system
of upgrading spells but an old system of
spell charges from Dark Souls unless
it's just a part of the debug mode he
also a spam changes his item from drop
stone of healing two drops fluid of
healing to glisten whatever that means
later in the gameplay is revealed that
the stones of healing are
of consumable divine blessings but estes
remains in the game however the role s
displays is unknown at this point and if
you look really closely you can see
small red bars under the equipped
weapons assumedly this is an easier way
to check your durability this next part
was one of my favorites not only does
the character pull out a gigantic sword
reminiscent of something from berserk he
actually interacts with projectiles this
dwarf thing through his axis at the
player and since the player can't dodge
he whacks the first one away with an
attack from his sword this could add a
new element of depth to encounters and
it's another example of the game being
more cinematic while still retaining a
focus on the gameplay it's also
interesting to note that here the player
character switches through three weapon
slots instead of two whether this was
just a showcasing feature for the demo
will remain to be seen look at the
lighting in this scene I'll slow it down
the light seamlessly interacts with the
character and I can't get over how
impressive that is this scene shows a
unique atmosphere I mentioned before
it's more reminiscent of demon souls and
that seems to be the case I always found
demon souls to be more creepier and this
blood-stained hallway full of paintings
and torture instruments is doing a
pretty good job of that also the castle
design seems a bit similar to boletaria
in Demon Souls now this next optional
encounter has been encouraged by the
devs as well as a change in the level
design based around it so now it seems
like when you encounter a major or minor
boss in the level is subject to change
and perhaps the difficulty of the enemy
is going to be relative to the
environment you actually decide to
encounter it in ten amira states he
wants to break that traditional element
of having a boss wait to be killed at
the end of the level expect level design
to change to suit this and I expect
bosses to come and hunt you down just
like the silver chariot Dark Souls 2 is
looking a lot more hostile another big
thing in this fight scene is how the
ranged combat has changed it looks so
much better now
you now have limited movement while
attacking and each arrow actually takes
a portion of your stamina meaning
movement and stamina manage
we'll be a much larger part of ranged
combat this is a great addition since
ranged combat in previous games has felt
like it was only situationally viable
now the bow seems to be a viable method
of taking on enemies in general also as
a side note notice the attention to
detail here as a painting falls down
when it's disturbed in this part the
player two hands his weapon and gets hit
with a glancing blow from the Cyclops
but he takes only a bit of damage it
seems like where you get hit could play
a part and you'll notice the sound that
hit makes almost sounds like it's
hitting the shield on the players back
something cool would be backstab
immunity when a shield is on your back
or even just the shield on the back
playing a part in the combat there's a
few things to note on the bridge say the
camera jerks around to disorient the
player when falling and also the falling
animation has been drastically improved
also this is more law-related but note
that he calls them wyverns not dragons
the last section of footage seems to
show that there's still a POI system in
the game since the character tanks 2
hits before being launched into the air
on the third other player interactions
were also mentioned in the interview and
we can expect no major changes here only
improvements 10 Amira promises more
interactions with the players and better
interactions through the server based
systems finally I'll close with one part
of the gameplay I can't answer 100%
where there should be a humanity counter
there's this strange symbol that sort of
looks like a moon or a Sun or an eclipse
what does this mean let me know what you
think I have one theory but it's just as
likely to be correct as yours
we know that weather or perhaps time of
day will play a bigger part in the game
there are also many references to this
one rope bridge
in the first trailer the bridge was
depicted in a cold snowy dark
environment in the gameplay it was a
sunny warm environment with Dragons all
around in the interview the developers
mentioned that we've seen this bridge
before so I assume it's the same one we
also know that time travel plays a part
in the game
perhaps the Eclipse symbol symbolizes
the state of the world perhaps you have
to go to a different world state to
cross the bridge however this is just
speculation that I read on Twitter
courtesy of investigative live
journalism it might be better suited to
my analysis of the trailer from a lore
point of view and speaking of which
that's the next video I'll upload I am
to have my lower analysis complete in
the coming week and I plan to use
community ideas in that video just as
much as my own ones also is a bit of a
postscript I'm sorry if this video
sounded a bit half-hearted I've had a
lot of trouble uploading because of
copyright issues and it's been really
frustrating and I just wanted to get
this video out as soon as possible so I
didn't take as much care with the audio
as I usually do anyway the lore video
was always going to be the one I put the
most emphasis on and hopefully you look
forward to that in the coming week later
guys
you